we just have the latest figures in
haven't we as far as the economy is
concerned inflation have fallen below 10
8.7 I think I'm right in saying that
you've got eight point seven percent
what difference will that make to our
viewers who are getting ready to go to
work this morning well it will make a
big difference to viewers because if
inflation starts to come down it things
means essentially things are slightly
getting less and less expensive although
it's important to remember it's not that
it's going down it's what the prices are
going down it's just that the rate at
which they are rising is going down the
issue is food inflation is still
extremely high at 19 and that really
hits some of the poorest households and
obviously food inflation matters because
it's Essentials that people can't
compromise on it's not luxury goods that
we can afford to go without so I think
unfortunately people won't necessarily
feel it as well as they might expect
considering the Fallen inflation but I
think nonetheless I think it will help
Rishi sunak and Jeremy Hunt are going to
see this as a massive win they're going
to say look our plan is working and try
and show that they're on track to get
inflation down to two percent by the end
of the year can they achieve it we'll
have to see